[Music]
aniko
is with us aniko is in bend oregon hi
nico how are you hi um
it's annika see i screwed it up i'm
sorry i was trying so hard what's up how
can i help it's so
it's okay my joke is i'm either on or
off
[Laughter]
okay i gotta tell you you came into my
life when my child was born
17 years ago and i've been a pretty good
kid i'm 51 years old and
i was ready to retire um
had no debt had a house
and had left my ex-husband
and my son set up to run a business that
we started which was a movie theater
and covid hit and killed us
um because we still kind of function as
a family
um divorced i
have i panicked i sold my house
to take my equity to limp the theater
along
um until all the coveted shutdown
stopped and
my ex-husband did a nice thing and took
over taking care of his
elderly father and bought a home and
went into construction and made money
because he needed to make money and i
had money
from equity to live on and so all this
got straightened out
and the goal has always been to let our
son take over this movie theater that
has helped us down
that was closed for 25 years that we had
refurbished and reopened after being
closed for 25 years as a historic
theater
um and i'm sitting here and
i'm hearing more about covert's death
and the possibility of things
closing again and i was so close dave i
followed all of your sits
and um currently i don't have any debt
except for the mortgage on the theater
and i can't get a bank to figure out how
to do a mixed
use loan for 460 000
on a property that is tax assessed at
850
000 i don't know what to do and i don't
want to make the wrong decision for my
son's
future success and i've got
your son's future success is not defined
by this theater
okay your son's future success is
defined by the work ethic and the
character
that you have passed on to him while you
worked on this theater
and the example that you and your ex
have set for your son
that's what his future success is going
to be based on
if ramsay investments ends up worth if
ramsay investments ramsey solutions ends
up worth nothing tomorrow
my kids are going to be just fine
because their future success is not
based on the value of this company
okay so you need to sell this stupid
theater it's a chain around your neck
it's a dream that turned into a
nightmare
that's what i heard did i miss something
no i'm sorry i'm crying
it's okay you you've invested so much
into this
it hurts and when you turn the key on
when you turn the key on a dream that
turns into a nightmare and you walk away
which is what we're doing while we're
talking right here it hurts like crap
your heart breaks
because you you've been heavily invested
in this
um and that just makes you human and it
means you were all in
it means you gave it everything you had
uh hey you didn't you didn't
you didn't invent coveted and you're in
your fault
you got you got screwed by a pandemic
can you sell the stupid thing now
um i had an interested party for
um the tax assessed value take it
and take it
take it so the the money that i would
make off of that would
i don't i i don't know what to do with
that money well you have 400 000
in your pocket sounds to me like right
i will yeah if i sell it no and a smile
on your face
and crap in your rear view mirror
i'm literally sitting in my car right
now at the dog park
[Laughter]
i lost well i gave up my dog's backyard
because we moved i moved into this
theater yeah
so go get you go get you a life back
this thing took everything from you now
you take it back
well i appreciate that you do what you
want to do if i woke up in your shoes
that's what i would do
i appreciate that i gotta look out for
this town
i think you're a good mom and i think
you gave something your haul
and it's time to cut bait let this one
go
let this one go move on 400 000 gives
you a fresh new start
you're not tied into your ex you and
your son can
you make a legacy for him you're still
young you got plenty of things you can
do here